en termes et si vous le voulez bien en
parlant d'un sujet à la fois médical et
professionnel
le burn-out ch cet épuisement
professionnel est il une maladie bat le
débat et est revenu ces derniers jours
parce que l'organisation mondiale de la
santé s'est épanché sur ce sujet pour
considérer finalement que c'était un
phénomène mais que ce n'était pas une
maladie julia de funès vous intervenez
souvent en entreprise
qu'est ce que c'est la différence entre
entre ces deux contrats faudrait
différence et c'est une maladie c'est
l'altération de la santé dont on connaît
la cause un syndrome c'est une
altération de la santé dont on ignore la
cause
ce qui est problématique avec le burn
out c'est que les causes sont très
polymorphe il ya plein on peut pas faire
un lien direct de cause à effet entre un
management harcelant s'il voulait et
puis un burn out chez le salarié c'est
trop compliqué les personnes qui
souffrent de burn-out parfois des
problèmes personnels qui s'additionnent
aux problèmes professionnels donc c'est
très difficile à d'assigner une cause
très précis c'est pour ça que ça peut
pas me semble-t-il du point de vue
rationnel rentrer dans la classification
maladie néanmoins la société va
tellement vers une psychopathologie
station de tous que je pense qu'à terme
ça rentrera évidemment dans la
classification maladie dès qu'il ya
souffrance et maladies dès qu'il ya
souffrance il ya victime aussi donc
mais en tout cas aujourd'hui on peut pas
l'on peut pas le définir comme une
maladie parce qu'on en ignore encore une
fois les causes parce que si j'avais eu
une maladie professionnelle à ce moment
là l'entreprise pourra être poursuivi
comme les rend responsables d'ong effet
c'est un peloton et l'histoire des
suicides à france télécom c'est bien sûr
qu'il ya un lien il ya des concomitance
il ya des relations évidemment très très
présente mais encore une fois à dire le
pdg est responsable du suicide c'est
beaucoup trop acrobatique comme lire un
suicide ça ce midi ça se prépare dans le
silence du coeur on peut pas sondé
toutes les raisons du mal être des
des âmes c'est vrai que la partie que
dans une même situation professionnelle
il ya des gens qui vont avoir un burnout
et d'autres pas ce qui ce qui tend à
penser qu'il ya des critères personnels
qui entre en cause son sort n'a c'est
indéniable mais je pense qu'à une
coresponsabilité finalement dans ce
phénomène c'est à dire qu'à la fois il
faut pas tomber dans le travers de la
société actuelle qui effectivement a
tendance à finalement faire de personnes
qui souffrent une victime qu'il faut
l'aider la bombe je pense que chacun a à
gérer
effectivement il ya apprendre à gérer
son rapport au travail que ça s'apprend
et qu' il faut aussi se placer face à
ses responsabilités quand parfois c'est
trop il faut savoir dire non etc
on peut trouver des appuis pour
apprendre à dire non enfin chacun doit
trouver ses propres chemins mais en
revanche ça ne doit pas être un argument
pour exonérer la responsabilité des
entreprises
on le sait très bien le management dans
les entreprises avec l'évolution de la
société des exigences de rendement etc
de productivité tout ce qu'on a maintes
fois détaillé partout dans les médias
tout ces dernières années ont quand même
mis en péril géant règles de management
des procédures qui pèse énormément sur
les individus un manque de
reconnaissance totale enfin un manque d
coûte donc ne pas interroger aussi ses
modes de fonctionnement serait un
problème et ce qui me choque un peu dans
la la la la justification à
l'argumentaire de la ms c'est que il ne
range pas ce burnout dans la catégorie
des maladies parce que considère que
c'est un saint homme en effet d'un
stress chronique mal géré donc on a
l'impression que c'est effectivement
simplement une question individuelle
je crois que là vraiment c'est une
erreur ça interpelle le mode de
fonctionnement des entreprises et qu' il
faut bien réfléchir mais c'est pas parce
que le burn-out faire une maladie que le
manager ne serait plus questionné non
plus donc de toutes façons ça n'a pas
tellement lien il faut questionner le
management aussi mais le burn out n'est
pas pour autant en tout cas aujourd'hui
reconnu c'est vraiment une interaction
je prendrai le burn out peut concerner
le management
bien sûr et certain de conserver le
manager puissamment situation soit
choisie chaque chose de très grand
stress professionnel dans certaines
circonstances bien donné avant de
continuer le trou discussion je propose
d'écouter ce témoignage de christophe
roth
c'est un des responsables de la cfe cgc
il est délégué national pour la santé et
il décrivait ce matin sur sud radio
toutes les toutes les conséquences
possibles d'un burn out
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui est victime
d'un épuisement professionnel d'un
syndrome d'épuisement professionnel
c'est une mort sociale
il a ce qu'on appelle la triple peine il
est à la fois avec un divorce
généralement il est à la fois avec des
difficultés financières et pour se
reconstruire il va devoir gérer c'est un
parcours du combattant qui peut durer
deux à trois ans sans forcément obtenir
des droits à la retraite parce qu'il
aura été parcours de carrière et bien
qu'ils seront comme des structures et
est aujourd'hui
oui il ya nécessité de la reconnaissance
alors vous êtes 64% sur twitter a estimé
que l' oms devrait reconnaître le burn
out comme une maladie ya cette analyse
de claire qui nous dit cette fatigue
professionnel est le résultat d'un
dysfonctionnement de notre société ça
peut devrait pourrait permettre une
véritable prise en charge et une
réflexion sur un changement de système
alors que l'homme considère que le burn
out est plutôt un ensemble de
d'affection qu'est ce que vous pensez de
sa alexandre ii vecchio j'avoue que je
n'ai pas à la vie est très arrêtée je
fais plutôt confiance aux médecins
venant mais qu'ils arrêtent ya un
dysfonctionnement dans le monde
du travail en fait il faut le traiter y
a pas besoin de déclarer le burn out
comme maladie pour traiter ce
dysfonctionnement la même je pense que
quelque part ce sera pire si on se
décharge on expliquait que c'était une
maladie on donne des indemnités aux gens
et on change pas le système si le
système est défaillant il faut il faut
le changer et pas mettre ça sur le
compte d'une maladie de demander des
indemnités au jour là de finesse on a
des des éléments contradictoires venant
du monde de l'entreprise sur ce sujet
vous y intervenait régulièrement
d'un côté on nous dit que la pression
augmente sans cesse et de l'autre côté
on a plein de plans qui sont mises en
six mises en place en particulier dans
les grandes sociétés pour être à
l'écouté des salariés
alors c'est quoi dans l'élite il ya un
paradoxe inouïe aujourd'hui il n'a
jamais fait le management n'a jamais
fait autant pour le bien-être des
salariés et des piscines des smoothie
viau de plantes vertes est bafouée n'ont
pas fermé des trucs des bonbons partout
enfin je vais vraiment dit ce n'est pas
une entreprise maintenant dans la vie
vous aviez donc c'est un vrai parc
d'attractions et en même temps il n'y a
jamais eu autant de mal être dans les
entreprises jamais autant de burn out de
bora ou de brain and out des arrêts
maladie qui nous raconte l'un d'eux
qu'est ce que c'est le bon round round
boring s'ennuyait choses et voir tout
l'absence de sens mais tout ça donc si
on ouvre la porte au burn out comme
maladie bien sûr que les autres
evidémment suez il ya un intérêt c'est
normal que 64% des gens soient
favorables au fait de mettre le burn out
dans la classification parce que on
on en retire quelques intérêts
évidemment mais ce qui est intéressant
dans ses nouvelles le maladie je trouve
c'est que ce ne sont plus du tout avant
en expliquer les névroses des psychoses
si je résume très schématiquement par un
conflit et par le conflit entre
l'individu et la société la norme
sociale m'impose des choses et mon désir
d'individus vient contrarier cette norme
sociale donc c'est ce qui crée toutes
ces maladies du conflit qui étaient des
névroses et les psychoses ce qui est
intéressant avec les nouvelles maladies
pas au sens classification oms main
nouvelle maladie c'est que ce ne sont
plus du tout des maladies de conflits de
culpabilité par rapport à une norme
ce sont des maladies qui sont liés à la
capacité l'incapacité en l'occurrence de
l'individu c'est plus du tout la même
chose on se confronte plus à à la
société bien sûr mais culpabilité pas
une norme par rapport à une norme
sociale a cédé culpabilité par rapport à
soi même
c'est toute la différence je n'arrive
pas à trouver un sens dans mon travail
je n'arrive pas à trouver à me ne pas
m'ennuyer je n'arrive pas à gérer la
charge
ce qui est d'autant plus difficile pour
un individu parce qu'effectivement la
culpabilité se retourne faire si je ne
suis pas capable de gérer alors que
l'entreprise fait en apparence tout pour
mon bien-être
ça génère un double malade pour joindre
pas tout à fait dans le sur le pont où
on peut se sentir on peut ne pas se
sentir à la hauteur de ce qui nous est
demandé donc là c'est une norme exogènes
ces normes extérieur qui s'annonçait
entreprises a dit oui mais ce n'est pas
une norme sociale cette année c'est ça
qui est contesté c'est cette pression là
c'est cette pression sur les régimes cd
oui alors c'est surtout l'absence de
sens pourquoi on m'impose temps alors je
ne vois même plus la finalité de ce que
je fais
l'individu est capable de supporter une
charge énorme de
on sait ce qu'on peut travailler
énormément simplement ça devient
problématique quand non seulement il ya
des injonctions contradictoires et
surtout qu'on ne voit plus du tout à
quoi en faire c'est souvent ça qui est
retrouvé dans les quatre dernières
commencèrent à titre individuel puisque
l'entreprise est de plus en plus une
sacré collectif ou ensemble on est un
maïs et lemoine est donc voila mais on
ne voit plus soi-même à quoi on va faire
ce qu'on ait reconnu soit mal à éviter
les 12es sur les way r34 nous fait ce
commentaire intéressant qui est une
question d'ailleurs qui apportera les
preuves de la réalité de la maladie
c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu comme
l'épreuve du harcèlement cc c'est
souvent difficile à qualifier
que pensez vous de cette mesure qui est
en vigueur dans beaucoup d'entreprises
qui est le droit à la déconnexion c'est
à dire l'idée qu' on ne faut plus entrer
en communication avec les salariés par
mail ou par texto en dehors des heures
de travail c'est un truc complètement
ridicule dans une époque connectés ou
une bonne idée moi personnellement c'est
totalement en contradiction avec tout
avec ma façon d'envisager une vie
professionnelle on ne peut pas à
certains à une certaine heure se
déconnecter mais c'est peut-être le fait
d'avoir été journaliste si pendant très
longtemps on est connecté en permanence
et on réagit en permanence et on revient
s'il ya quelque chose à faire et quand
on a rien à faire on part et voilà il
faut cette liberté là et cette capacité
en plus et percus et ça c'est droit à la
déconnexion c'est encore une maniaque
aux législations et on n'a pas les 110
qui est malade de législation il faut le
droit à la déconnexion maintenant on est
légal aux fils sous sap et collaborant
avec il ya une liberté possible il faut
que ce soit comment faire face à des
effectifs en les managers qui donc se
permettre de lever demain
alors oui ça c'est que ça soit autorisée
ou surface et facile à dire
est ce que si on la devine amis de ne
pas répondre à son boss et bars dire je
pense que c'est pas si simple et
sympathique simple mais je veux dire
s'il avait une force et un courage c'est
pas individualiser partie d'un collectif
s'est amusé est-ce qu'il va passer sa
vie personnelle
ouais mais je pense qu'il peut tout à
fait se lire car les retombées
bénéfiques à un discours de l'entreprise
moi je pense que ça suffit pas de dire
encore une fois je suis tout à fait
sensible le fait que chacun doit avoir
sa propre hygiène professionnel et je
pense qu'il ya aussi un discours de
l'entreprise à avoir sur sa sur le
respect des temps des individus
fin juillet le temps de les visionner
peut-être mais avec encore une fois une
philosophie commune de l'entretien mais
je trouve que les managers franchement
ont un peu ce discours là maintenant le
management très paternaliste
autoritariste style france télécom est
passée de mode met en scène un crime
parce que les gens les salariés sont
annoncés individuelle de se
responsabiliser de dire là je réponds
pas c'est tout